une histoire d'amour en chanson
Jacqueline vient chaque mois dans ce thé
dansant de la commune de plaisir une
appétence pour la musique partagée avec
ses amis et une rencontre inattendue
célibataire durant 20 ans elle fait la
connaissance de Michelle dans ce lieu en
2018 le début d'une relation complice
autour de la passion du tango je venais
danser depuis quelques année et un beau
jour je l'ai rencontré en dansant il est
venu m'inviter une fois deux fois d'cord
puis puis voilà puis on est reparti
ensemble on s'est tout de suite entendu
pour la danse hein bon mais après il y a
eu un peu plus quoi et
voilà rendez-vous mensuel incontournable
pour les senior de plaisir et de ses
alentours depuis mai 2017 ce thé
dansansant est installé dans la salle
des fêtes des gaâtines passe au doblé
Vals twist ou rock quelques notes de
musique pour rompre la solitude un temps
d'évasion pour certains après
interruption du à la pandémie de
covid-19 au départ nos seigneorss
étaient un petit peu frileux bien
évidemment ça ça peut se se comprendre
mais mais par la suite nous avons vu une
recrudesence de de participation leur
permet de sortir de chez eux de voir du
monde discuter avec d'autres personnes
et de passer un bon après-midi avec un
goûé 16h lors d'une pause bien méritée
boisson et pâtisserie pour reprendre des
forces entre entre 80 et 100 danseurs
viennent à chaque rendez-vous pour
fouler la piste un moment chaleureux de
partage que ces deux copines ne
manqueraient sous aucun prétexte on fait
plein de rencontres on est avec nos amis
et puis tout le monde pleurait qu'il y
avait pas de thé dansant maintenant
qu'on a un thé dansant ben on participe
he alors moi je viens surtout parce que
j'aime beaucoup danser on aime bien pu
on retrouve pas mal de copines et on
discute bon on trouve quelquefois des
bons danseurs c'est très agréable
programmé chaque premier jeudi du mois
le thé dansansang de plaisir coûte 15 €
par personne collation comprise quelques
pas échanger pour mieux découvrir
l'autre le temps d'une chanson ou d'une
vie
[Musique]
entière